everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're going to be
going over one of my favorite openings
and that's the fried liver attack and it
starts with pawn to e4 pawn e5 Knight f3
development knight c6 development and
Bishop to c4 the Italian game now I do
want to let you know that the fried
liver attack is a very very aggressive
opening so if you're not an aggressive
player feel free to watch this video and
enjoy it and learn something hopefully
but you're probably not gonna like this
opening a lot of times people who are
very passive like to kind of build up in
a defense getting to the in game
methodically win a game I don't really
play like that I like to attack attack
attack and win the game early and as
fast as I possibly can but that's not
everyone so with that said from here
you're really gonna see two things if
you see the Bishop come down to c5 which
is very common the gioco piano you can
bring your pawn to b4 and I say this
only because this is the Evans gambit I
play it very frequently and it is very
aggressive so if you're already getting
ready for the fried liver attack then if
they do play Bishop to c5 go ahead and
have something in your back pocket if
they don't play the two Knights defense
which the fried liver attack comes from
but if they don't play Bishop to c5 here
then more than likely you will see the
knight come to f6 very common move from
black it's the two Knights defense
against the Italian game and from here
here's really where the fried liver
attack takes off White's gonna continue
with Knight to g5 and as you can already
see we're starting to put a lot of
pressure on this f7 pawn as many of you
know the f7 pawn is a key weakness for
black and in the last video we talked
about if you play e4 then you're gonna
have a lot more opportunities to attack
this pawn on f7 this square in
particular as you can see here we
already have two of our minor pieces
King down on this f7 square so black
from here more than likely will bring
his pawn to d5 this is the main line
that you'll see trying to alleviate some
of this pressure and at the same time he
has two defenders against this
on here so he's trying to block off this
bishop that's eyeing down on this pawn
on f7
since we do have an additional defender
here with our night on g5 so from here
we're going to take with our pawn this
pawn really does nothing for us in the
fried liver attack so we're just gonna
go ahead and get rid of it and the
Knights not gonna come to d5 again and
can't bring his Queen here because then
we would just take his queen but at the
same time he still wants to alleviate
some of this pressure against this f7
square so he needs to take back and
again we are attacking his night here on
c6 so you're gonna see his knight come
to d5 and as you can see here now white
has an option that he can choose to do
and that is take on f7 and that's the
fried liver attack and from here as you
can see that we are attacking not only
this Queen here on d8 but we're also
attacking this rook here on h8 so from
here although I'm not gonna say good or
bad black really needs to take this
knight on f7 because it's attacking out
only this Queen but this rook here so if
he doesn't take then we're going to take
one of these pieces we're going to not
only be at this pawn on f7 but we're
also going to be up this exchange for
either a rook or queen and from here
this is where it really gets aggressive
because Y is just going to start to
throw everything at the King and try to
win the game by checkmate early on in
the game now I do want to let you know
I'm gonna be going over a lot of the
main moves and a few of the variations
that you may see but keep in mind in the
fried liver attack there are many many
many different types of games that can
be played so if I don't cover every
single game don't freak out and say
Kevin you didn't cover such-and-such
because there's just hundreds and
hundreds of different variations but I
will go over some of the main points
that you do want to keep in the back of
your mind when you do play the fried
liver attack and a lot of the moves are
the same over and over so as long as you
know the main moves then you
be completely okay the next move is
Queen to f3 and then King to e6 now this
is very important because again keep in
mind we now even though we're attacking
this King on f7 and we've gained a tempo
here developed our Queen and forced the
King to move this black to move his King
here he still needs to defend this
knight on d5 if he doesn't bring his
King to e6 then we can go ahead and take
this night here on d5 and really have a
good game and also keep in mind if you
try something really bad like King to g8
then we can bring our Bishop take on d5
he can't move his king here so he can
take with his Queen we can take back
with our queen check but the only move
that he has is Bishop to e6 and then we
take a niche checkmate so just keep in
mind he could make some bad moves if he
wanted to but his best move is going to
be e 6 the really only other move that I
have seen is King to be 8 but then keep
in mind that we can bring our Bishop to
d5 take and he can't take back because
our Queen here on f3 as you can see
already we're up in material and at the
same time we have a lot of aggressive
momentum that we have going on here
we're looking at Queen to f7 for
checkmate our Bishop is still very
active and this is going to be a very
good game for white if he tries to block
this with Queen to e7 again he doesn't
have a lot of options to protect this f7
square then we can bring our Bishop to
c6 take on this and then he really would
needs to move his King here if he takes
with his pawn on b6 then we can retake
I'll show you here and check and at the
same time we are attacking this
work on a a so again blacks just in a
very bad bad position if he brings his
King to g8 or EI and also if we come
back to it even if he doesn't do that if
he just tries King to e7 well this is
just a really bad spot for him one he's
gonna lose this night but at the same
time now he's completely blocked off his
Bishop his dark square Bishop here on
ethics not only is he gonna be down a
lot of material but he can't even
develop his pieces so this is gonna be
very good for white but most of what
we're gonna be talking about today is
King to e6 since this is the most common
and this is really what King the black
King really has to play in order to
continue to have a fighting chance now
from here what's going to continue with
Knight to c3 and all these moves so far
this Queen to f3 in this Knight to c3
they're all gonna be the same so don't
worry about ha you know how do I
remember all these moves the few
beginning moves in the fried liver
attack are all the same here as you can
see this is not only a develop move but
this is a strong move because we're only
adding more pressure on this knight on
d5 in the square in general and he can't
take this Knight he again you can't even
move this Knight because it's being
pinned down with our Bishop here on c4
so from here black really has two
options that you will see the first one
is bringing his knight to b4 and he's
doing two things he's trying to
alleviate some of this pressure on d5 by
adding another defender but the same
time he's Iying down this pawn here on
c2 now from here there are a few moves
I'm gonna go ahead and recommend what I
like the best but there are a few moves
that you can do here one of the most
popular moves is pawn to a3 and what
this really does is it kind of forces
black to bring his knight to see to and
you're like well Kevin you know we're
forcing this Knight to take our rook on
a1 but if you play the fried liver
attack on
you really know that it's all about the
active pieces that you have and usually
this work here on a1 doesn't get a lot
of place so if we can sacrifice this
rook to get this Knight here out of the
way that's completely fun
so from here our King is gonna come to
d1 and then the Knights gonna come to a1
and capture and this is completely fun
because now we're just going to start to
throw everything in the kitchen sink at
the black King and we really just
removed this defender here so again this
is a very aggressive opening and we're
going to be sacrificing trying to win
the game early on now from here why it's
gonna continue and he's going to capture
with his knight on d5 really putting his
knight in great spot at the same time
black really needs to bring his king to
d6 he can't bringing along this F file
but if he doesn't move his King then we
were gonna have a discovered attack once
we move our knight here
now from here white can continue he
really wants to move this pawn on D in
this D file so he can activate his dark
square bishop and this is a great spot
for it because this pawn here on e5 is
only getting out of our way and this
pawn we don't really care about we're
just moment basically focused with our
major pieces and our minor pieces here
so after he takes we can now bring our
Bishop to F for attacking this is gonna
be a very easy win from white the Kings
out in the middle and we have all of our
pieces attacking the black King the next
thing you might see instead of taking on
a1 he may bring his knight to d4 which
is probably a little better spot form so
it doesn't have his knight out of the
way from here we can continue take on d5
again let's go and take material and you
can't recapture with this Queen over
this King because we have our night here
at the same time he can bring his King
now we really want to keep attacking so
we're gonna bring our Queen here to g3
again pinning down this pawn here at the
same time getting it away of this night
here on d4 now it doesn't really matter
where black moves but next move we're
really going to want to bring our pawn
to d3 too so that we can activate our
dark square Bishop again the black Kings
in the middle and we're starting to
develop all of our pieces
so that we can continue our attack in
the last minute that you may come across
you may see Knight to e7 here from here
we can continue we can actually castle
on the King side and then doesn't really
matter where black goes a lot of times
you'll see pawn to c6 trying to add a
lot more pressure on this d5 Square and
we can bring our rook to e1 getting
ready for pawn to d4 which is just a
brutal move for black again we have our
rook that's pinning down that pawn on e5
and there's nothing that black can
really do because once we play this pawn
we can then activate our dark square
Bishop and we're really just gonna be
attacking the King in the center of the
board until we check them so this is the
fried liver attack hopefully you guys
enjoyed if you haven't already please
subscribe and I'll see you guys in the
next video